[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce 7,8 sport le
magazine est consacrée comme vous le
savez à l'actualité sportive dans le
département à ces parties a pour le
sommaire volley ball les féminines de
vélizy confirment leur bon début de
saison les billysienne se sont imposés 3
sets à 0 contre châteaudun domicile et
conserve la tête du classement de
nationale 3 plus d'informations dans ce
magazine golf la nouvelle est tombée la
semaine dernière le prochaine open de
france va être déplacé dans le
calendrier et perd son statut de rolex
series coup de projecteur et analyses à
suivre dans quelques instants
voilà les deux yvelinois louis burton
éric bellion ont pris le départ de la
célèbre route du rhum depuis le port de
saint malo est devant à des milliers de
spectateurs et tenteront de rejoindre le
plus rapidement possible à google ou
pour retour sur leurs premiers jours en
mer l'actualité sportive c'est
maintenant sur tv à 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par du volley ball tous
les signaux sont au vert pour l'équipe
féminine de vélizy en nationale 3 ce
week-end les sportives yvelinois se sont
imposés 3 sets à 0 contre châteaudun et
conserve la tête du championnat
remontage de à xavier jaglin des images
de patrick jacques de dixmude les
féminines de vélizy peuvent exulter les
sportifs viennent de remporter leur
cinquième victoire de la saison six
matches disputés
leur victime du jour châteaudun
lévisienne s'impose dans leur gymnase 3
sets à 0 le score 25 à 20 25 11 et 25 à
balade de santé dans le premier set qui
n'était pas la réalité sociale justement
c'est en psycho logiquement se met
dedans et après par la suite
effectivement ça s'est érodée on a été
plus propre dans le fond que je cède
cole satisfait par rapport à la causerie
d'avant match
justement on a essayé d'appuyer sur le
fait de jouer ensemble se faire plaisir
et de tenir le jeu qu'on a par la tenue
sur les derniers matches dans la
régularité donc bonne réaction des
filles
avec cette victoire les bélizienne
conserve la première place du
championnat de nationale 3 devant
argenteuil et le promu ne s'enflamme pas
donc l'ac thann et c'est une année de
plaisir maintenant les filles commencent
à chercher justement à faire des
résultats
mais les objectifs du club
ces deux matches 7 maintenir moi c'est
d'essayer de fallout a beau et puis ça
va et puis ici sont gourmandes donc on
va voir si c'est pour continuer à rêver
d'une montée en nationale 2 vélizy devra
s'imposer le 17 novembre prochain face à
son dauphin au classement argenteuil une
victoire est les yvelinoises pourrait
déjà une sérieuse option sur la première
place
on reste à vélizy avant le match des
filles l'équipe masculine affrontés à
saint-avertin un sport à domicile pour
le compte de la 6e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 et les
billysiens ont remporté réussi à
s'imposer 3 sets à 1 une victoire qui
leur permet de grimper à la troisième
place on écoute les réactions au micro
de notre journaliste patrick jacques de
dixmude 3 c'est pas mal on a bien servi
on a su on a su te reprend sur des
moments où c'était un peu compliqué
notamment au bloc on a été
on a été assez performant et
voilà le service est très simple on
continue par du football la direction la
première division de district 6e journée
ce week-end plaisir s'est imposé dans la
douleur 2-1 contre marly le roi lui en
cours domine sartrouville 3-2 maurepas
s'incline 3-0 contre où il y à
l'extérieur c'était journée à portes
ouvertes dans la défense de montesson
les joueurs ont pris l'eau sur le
terrain de carrière gré si on dit saint
leu chesnais s'offrent le fc mantois à 4
à 3 dans un festival offensif
enfin à gargenville s'impose contre
hardricourt 3 1 le championnat est
dominée apparu en cours on continue à
part du football dans le championnat de
nationale 3 c'était le choc de cette 8e
journée
versailles n'a pu faire mieux que match
nul sur le terrain de colomb score final
1 partout
au classement les versailles et pointe à
la 3e place à deux petits points du
leader avec un bilan de 4 victoires 3
nuls et une défaite depuis le début du
championnat
toujours en football dans le championnat
de régionale 3 a comme versailles le
club de trappes n'a pu faire mieux que
match nul 1 partout sur son terrain
contre saint-ouen-l'aumône
un résultat qui permet tout de même aux
trappistes de prendre la tête du
championnat à la différence de buts et
surtout de continuer leur série à
d'invincibilité
on ouvre maintenant une page à basket
dans le championnat de nationale 3 trap
a confirmé ce week-end son bon début de
saison les trappistes en dominé à blois
à l'extérieur sur le score de 87 à 73
une victoire à qui leur permet de rester
à la deuxième place du championnat pour
nous parler de ce début de saison à
canon nous recevons sur ce plateau le
président jacques michel et et mme
mohamud diakité qui joue à l'intérieur
ou à l
ça dépend des fois bonsoir alors c'est
une victoire assez facile quand même ce
samedi soir pas facile le score pourrait
laisser penser en fait il fallait que le
qui peut se reconcentre reprennent
reprenne la maîtrise de son jeu
quelques elle repense son jeu collectif
notamment de façon à reprendre sa
confiance en elle-même qu'elle avait en
début d'année et qui a connu une
une petite baisse pendant pendant deux
matches là voilà ce qui nous semblait
trop fait mais bien sûr aucun résultat
de la suite n'est garanti ça a été un
excellente enseignements que d'avoir que
d'avoir ce petit petite baisse de forme
là qui nous a dit qu'il fallait vraiment
que l'on se donne pleinement et qu'on ne
pense pas l'ailé des scores acquis alors
sur ce match vous avez surtout réussi à
remporter le dernier quart temps 23 à 15
ça prouve que l'équipe était bien
mentalement et physiquement ça va ça
qu'on en avait besoin comme le président
a expliqué c'est qu'on avait une petite
peste notamment c'est dommage avant on
avait perdu car en fait on sait commune
et qu'une nouvelle équipe est mal de
nouveaux joueurs donc on est encore en
construction mais petit à petit au fur
et à mesure des matches on sent que
commencera la confiance commence à
revenir et faire et physiquement aussi
si on n'a pas cette rencontre si on
regarde le score 23 à 15 dans le déni
carton c'est vrai sur la fin il se
reprendre parce que déjà même là de la
première mi temps ça n'allait pas trop
on n'avait pas trop les a pas trop de
rythme en fait et voilà elle a fallu
juste que tout de suite quoi après cette
victoire vous êtes donc deuxièmes du
classement comment l'expliquez
finalement ce résultat alors que les
dernières saisons était un petit peu
compliqué oui vous avez raison c'est le
mercato qui a fait la différence et oui
on peut dire ça
on peut dire ça mais pas seulement
mercato c'est qu'en fait dans les
saisons passées on a commencé à
construire un noyau dur de l'équipe et
que même si à peu près la moitié de
l'équipe a été renouvelée cette année
ce noyau dur a été là pour faciliter
également l'intégration d'un ensemble de
nouveau même si les nouveaux hôtes une
place tout à fait importante et il
n'empêche que le jeu ce n'est pas
d'abord de la technique c'est d'abord un
esprit et je crois que justement cet
esprit et bien en train de prendre comme
de dit mahmoud
ça a pris beaucoup plus vite que les
années précédentes
vous confirmez le groupe vit bien oui
c'est exactement ça très bon groupe
pas plus parce qu'on essaie déjà de
paravent s'étaient rencontrés dans
d'autres clubs et de tous réunis par mam
équipe c'est parfait c'est ce que vous
désirez peut-être président aussi peut
être privilégier l'aspect humain à
l'aspect technique peut-être dans un
recrutement bien bien sûr qu'il faut
savoir jouer au basket
ça me paraît absolument évident mais la
différence effectivement ne se fait pas
forcément sur le plan purement technique
mais bien sûr l'harmonique possible des
joueurs entre eux et dans le jeu et de
ce point de vue là justement ce n'est
pas une donnée seulement techniques il
ne faut pas comprendre il faut ressentir
et je dirais que il faut être le
complice de l'autre et des autres en
général
le basket est de ce point de vue là un
sport qui collectif qui est
particulièrement je dirais serré qui
demande une très grande attention est
constante
que ce soit en attaque ou en défense la
solidarité tout à fait première parce
qu'il ne suffit pas de marquer son point
il faut que les autres marques mois
justement si on regarde votre début de
saison vous inscrivez beaucoup de points
comme le disait le président 87 ce
week-end 112 contre séguinière lors de
la première journée
comment l'expliquer cette réussite
offensive
c'était peut-être pas la motivation de
photos monde étant des victimes ont
arrêté ça veut pas dire dream team c'est
vrai que sur la fin on est une très
grosse équipe pour ça c'est un peu
dallas mais après bon voilà je passe en
version poser ses acquis et continuer à
bosser au fur et à mesure de la saison
je pense que on pourrait faire encore
mieux que ça il équipe n'encaisse pas
forcément beaucoup de points parce que
sur le match contre séguinière vous avez
marqué 112 points
certes mais vous n'en avez encaissé que
53 ouais c'est vrai ça c'est vrai que
physiquement on avait quand même de te
sur eux donc j'ai vu tout de suite quoi
c'est travailler à l'entraînement
vraiment la défense c'est travailler
même si on pourra travailler car un peu
plus vous êtes d'accord il faut une
grosse défense attrape parce que c'est
un peu dans les gènes de l'équipe 1
finalement d'avoir cette grosse défense
personnellement je disais malgré les
résultats je disais écoute et voilà vous
êtes capable de marquer des paniers et
sa lancée vous devriez pas en prendre
autant et c'est ce qui est arrivé sur
les deux matches que nous avons perdu
c'est que ils ont été eux mêmes surpris
et cette surprise a déstabilisé
justement cette harmonie cette harmonie
de l'attak et et bien ça à pédaler un
petit peu donc vous êtes deuxième il
faut éviter le faux rires si je
comprends bien absolument absolument
mais est ce qu'une prochaine on
rencontre les les troisième fois qu'ils
sont pour l'instant même les les
premiers puissent y aura match en moins
et puis la semaine suivante on rencontre
ce qui sont les premiers vineuil
également donc là on aura deux
véritables récents dans la saison ce
sont tout à fait la suite c'est quoi
c'est une montée à votre avis pour pour
travaux ils ont parlé en tout cas entre
vous oui c'est sûr on en parle du début
de saison qu'on est en train de faire on
se dit mais c'est c'est possible quoi si
on peut le faire si vraiment le veut
affaire à suivre
est ce que le président met un peu la
pression joueur pour une saison
ça n'est pas là ce n'est pas la pression
au sens où on l'entend autrement dit ce
n'est pas une menace c'est un espoir
c'est un challenge et je crois que
justement lorsque je parlais tout à
l'heure d'esprit c'est que tous les
joueurs d'une manière très rapide ont
été capables virouil c'est vrai au fond
il faut pas qu'on se la joue perso
il faut qu'on soit une équipe il faut
qu'on reprenne les qualités humaines que
que l'on avait montré en début d'année
notamment dans cette mise en route du
mois d'août avec pourtant un nouvel
entraîneur de nouveaux joueurs tout ça
avait marché d'une manière tout à fait
assez extraordinaire il faut jamais
s'endormir sur ses lauriers
cette expérience que nous avons eus je
l'espère nous sera très profitable dont
je dis nous si au collectif joueurs et
dirigeants compris
dernière question rapidement votre
prochain match est programmé ce samedi
soir à domicile au gymnase paul mallet
contre laurent de la plaine les
troisièmes du classement
un pronostic rapidement leader de
trappes c'est oui c'est ce que je dirai
que pour atteindre les objectifs qu'on
s'est très clairement défini il faut
gagner il faut gagner dans votre
victoire de travaux dict
moi c'est ce que je veux 300 merci à
tous les deux passés sur ce plateau vous
souhaite une montée en fin de saison et
j'espère qu'on fera cela sur ce plateau
merci encore merci bon à manger des
ballons de basket et on va sortir les
balles de golf dans ce set 8 sport
mauvaise nouvelle pour l'open de france
le rendez vous saint quentinois va
quitter les meilleurs tournois européens
faute de gros sponsors le tournoi sera
aussi déplacé dans le calendrier le
rendez vous se jouera à l'année
prochaine au mois d'octobre à montage de
jules grandes villes coup dur pour
l'open de france de golf l'european tour
l'organisateur des tournois européens
décidé de lui retirer son statut de
rolex séries en 2019 d'un cependant
assez important le rendez vous est donc
éjecté des huit tournois les plus
importants du vieux continent est classé
ne sont pas être comment approprié
l'open change de date ses certitudes
mais déclassé il reste toute façon les
profs du bureau penneteau ça ne vient
pas il est produite chaque jour donc on
utilise en général le terme des classes
et quand une épreuve où une équipe passe
de première division
deuxième division ce n'est clairement
pas le cas mais c'est pas à l'aune d'une
édition qu' il faut évaluer la valeur
d'une épreuve
il faut essayer de remettre aussi tous
un petit peu en perspective autre
changement le tournoi sera déplacé dans
le calendrier 2010 neuf lots rendez-vous
le se jouera plus la dernière semaine de
juin golf national de saint quentin en
yvelines mais du 17 au 20 octobre
l'open de france en juin a pu souffrir
par le passé d'une trop grande proximité
de dates avec roland garros où avec le
tour de france ou avec leur au mondial
de foot
donc on pense qu'en étant remplacé en
deuxième partie de saison là on a un
coup à jouer si on peut dire il reste
encore une inconnue sur le prochain open
de france la dotation elle devrait
passer de 7 millions de dollars un peu
moins de 3 millions d'euros suite à la
perte de son statut le plateau de
joueurs devraient par conséquent être
moins relevé pour débriefer cette
nouvelle sur l'open de france de golf
lors au second sur ce plateau notre
consultant au golf pierre chevallier qui
a assisté à la dernière ryder cup
il a pu voir également de nombreux open
de france en ile et groupe lui-même
d'ailleurs comment allez vous fier à
travers mikari bonsoir alors comment ce
déclassement est perçu dans le monde
golfique français ja il ya deux il ya
deux aspects le verre à moitié plein au
verre à moitié vide
si on regarde le verre à moitié vide
c'est surtout la brutalité de l'annonce
voir brutalité la soudaineté de la non
ce qui a surpris puisque voilà mercredi
dernier ce qui si on repart un petit pas
en arrière au moment de la ryder cup
à saint quentin le calendrier n'était
pas encore arrêté donc ce n'était pas
encore assez d pas encore disputer ni
arrêté que le quai l'open de france
change de date
ce qui est ce qui était déjà sur c'était
que le le sponsor principal avait avait
fait ses valises et chinois c'est la
chesnaie y voilà avait avait repris sa
dotation était parent était parti je
suis à perdre et si par manque de
financement en fait tout simplement pas
mal et c'est parti évoquer réseaux
l'ingénierie trois ans plus deux en
option
voilà une raison économique évoquée
après le sur le côté officieux c'est
peut-être que après après une raideur
que qui est peut-être moins deux il ya
peut-être moins d'intérêt au moins deux
oui moins d'intérêt à léa les
sponsoriser l'open l'open français donc
c'est vraiment la soudaineté à la fois
de l'annonce non pas du déclassement
mais de la perte du statut de rolex
series et puis et puis du déplacement du
déplacement de la date du mois de fin
juin début juillet à octobre qui avait
surpris le monde le monde le film
français c'est un petit peu on va dire
une petite une petite gueule de bois
peut-être ou le soufflé qui retombe
après la après la ryder cup on a eu une
montée en puissance émise mise en abyme
mise en lumière médiatique du golf
français pendant deux ans notamment vers
l'amont terrain à la ryder cup avec un
événement absolument fantastique fin
septembre sur les greens du golf
national
et puis donc là peut-être eu une petite
gueule de bois / lesure sur l'après
ryder cup refait dû être peut-être être
un peu plus clément peut-être difficile
à dire s'il était déjà déjà dense et
blanc a imaginé suit d'abord au retrait
de cheney qui est déjà dans ses plans à
vouloir à vouloir des déclassés le
déclasser le pôle tournoi et de le
déplacer en termes de en terme de date
maintenant maintenant je pense qu'il
fait il faut qu'on voie côté gaulle
français qu'on voit le verre à moitié
plein pour contraire en disant qu'il ya
peut-être des avantages à le voir à le
voir déplacer à le voir se jouer au
niveau au milieu d'eux au milieu ou au
début de l'automne sera pas un peu moins
glamour quand même que le l'a d'ailleurs
ce maître de juin début juillet il ya un
aspect météo sociale c'est sûr il ya un
aspect météo qui est qui qui peut jouer
mais si on regarde un petit peu le côté
réchauffement climatique on avait des
fortes chaleurs si vous voir qu'une
canicule en jeu en juin juillet donc et
je me souviens de certaines certaines
éditions de l'open qui sont joués sous
des températures absolument record de 40
degrés qu'il était né agréable ni pour
les joueurs ni pour les spectateurs
et puis là on sort du nom sort des
vacances de la toussaint et puis de 2,7
de cette météo tss et de ceux de cet été
indien assez incroyable à donner des
idées européennes voilà peut-être que
seront faites le le climat automnal de
50 ans initié plus ahutoru européen pour
jouer un beau tournoi
il y à entre 25 et 30 mille spectateurs
à peu près par édition de l'open de
france allait pour les années ça dépend
du plateau est ce que vous pensez qu'il
y aura autant de personnes il peut y
avoir moins ça va dépendre aussi des
vacances scolaires mine de rien ça ça
joue quand même beaucoup sur le
calendrier des spectateurs et on fera
pas des téléspectateurs mais des
spectateurs au moins et puis ça peut
jouer aussi de manière positive ça peut
ça peut trouver sa place dans un
calendrier d'octobre qui est moins
chargée en événements sportifs par
exemple ce qui n'était pas le cas jean
juillet coincé entre le tour de france
l'année prochaine y aura l'oeil aura là
l'euro féminin donc la coupe du monde
féminine de foot il ya différents gros
événements qui sont qui se télescopent à
cette période là en octobre à parle à
part le tournoi de tennis le tournoi de
tennis qui se joua qui se joue en ce
moment
s'il ya un petit peu plus de place pas
médiatiquement et les joueurs vont-ils
se déplacer sur ce tournoi peut-être
parce que cette date là donc c'est
l'avant dernier tournoi de l'année
exactement et s'est donc élevé c'est
l'italienne open qui qui va prendre la
place que calais c'est l'open de france
qui a dû laisser l'open de france
mais il ya encore il ya encore une
petite course aux points dans cette foi
en cette fin de saison et peut-être
justement les derniers points qui sont à
glaner pour les cartes européenne
donneront l'occasion à certains joueurs
de se présenter sur l'open sur l'open de
france
même avec la météo qui sera moins
clément dont on pensait qu'il y aura
autant de joueurs on peut espérer que m
notons par exemple s'était plaint du
froid lors de la dernière ryder cup
alors que le thermomètre affiche et à 20
degrés sur les derniers automne en a pas
on n'a plus eu de contre exemple avec un
automne plutôt radieux et avec un été
indien qui devrait permettre à certains
quand même de pointer le bout de leur
nez
pire avec au pire avec un baudet
peut-être pas d'américains merci pierre
chevalier pour votre analyse sur
l'avenir de l'open de france de golf on
vous retrouvera prochainement dans
l'émission à 6 ans par les sports sur tb
78 une émission dont vous êtes l'un des
chroniqueurs
je vais plaisir merci beaucoup nous
allons maintenant prendre le large dans
cette émission le départ de la route du
rhum a été donné ce dimanche depuis le
port de saint-malo des skippers se sont
élancés pour rejoindre la guadeloupe en
solitaire parmi eux 2 illinois louis
burton originaire de rambouillet et éric
bellion de versailles le premier a pris
la route sur son imoca bureau vallée
mais son aventure pourrait rapidement se
terminer le skipper est actuellement en
train de réparer son bateau à roscoff
suite à une avarie au niveau de son
puits de foil ce qui entraînait une
infiltration par voie d'eau sur 30 cm et
va tenter de repartir dans les
prochaines heures de son côté éric
bellion le skipper de comme un seul
homme et 14e du classement dans les
bateaux hors catégorie mais semble avoir
des problèmes à technique
on passe maintenant notre chronique
juniors tous les mois notre journaliste
mélanie poké nous rejoint sur ce plateau
pour nous à présenter des activités
sportives pour les atouts petibon sort
mais l'ami on ça alors aujourd'hui
direction lit de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines pour parler
équitation le centre équestre sky
équitation accueille tous les publics et
même les plus jeunes
mais dany c'est vers ça mais l'école à
son poney club a décidé au moins de 6
ans il ya du baby poney et un cours
moustiques alors le premier c'est pour
les 4-5 ans le deuxième c'est pour les 2
3 ans un stage se dérouler pendant les
vacances scolaires de la toussaint
julien guennec et moniteur d'équitation
ça permet de sensibiliser les enfants à
pendant une semaine autour du poney ça
permet de l'art développé un petit peu
les sens des responsabilités tout ça de
pouvoir s'occuper d'un être vivant
voilà c'est vraiment à quelque chose
c'est vraiment la semaine de stage leur
permet vraiment de s'habituer d'avoir
des bons réflexes avec les animaux alors
comme les grands les cavaliers
découvrent leurs montures les brosses
les prépare et très vite ils montrent
leurs poneys et alterne les petites
activités slalom parcours et même un peu
de voltige donc on a apprend un petit
peu à comment se comporter autour du
poney à les familiariser avec l'animal
et à vaincre un petit peu leur première
appréhension
les premiers contacts avec l'animal et
ensuite c'est vraiment que du ludique on
leur apprend pas forcément de la
technique mais on leur apprend en
s'amusant
alors les vacances de la toussaint sont
terminées mais des activités continues à
mehdaoui notamment pour les 4-5 ans sky
équitation fait durer le plaisir
les trois dimanches suivants ceux de
novembre donc le baby poney continue de
11h30 à 12h30
ils forment peut être les futurs
champions olympiques 1 de demain mais
dhamir merci beaucoup en tout cas merci
pour toutes ces précisions on passe
maintenant notre page agenda
[Musique]
on commence cette page agenda part du
rugby le match à ne pas manquer ce
week-end si vous êtes un passionné de
ballon ovale c'est celui-là le sky
reçoit l'entente maisons laffitte
saint-jean mansle et poissy pour un
derby haut rhinois qui sent la poudre
les saint quentinois sont cinquièmes du
classement et le mlsgp est 1er avec une
seule défaite depuis le début de la
saison
si vous voulez assister à cette
rencontre le match est programmé ce
dimanche à 15 heures au stade du bout
des clous à maurepas toujours anguilles
mais cette fois ci un étage plus bas
dans le championnat de promotion honneur
montigny le bretonneux reçoit aulnay ce
dimanche à 15 heures au stade roger
couderc pour le choc de cette 5e journée
lésigny montrent un deuxième tenteront
de prendre le fauteuil de leader d'aulne
et les deux équipes ne sont séparées que
par deux petits points
pour réaliser cet exploit monti le boat
ne appelle tous ses fans à se déplacer
pour ce premier tournant de la saison
et puis en cyclisme un rendez vous qu'il
ne faudra absolument pas manquer si vous
êtes un fan de cyclisme sur piste ce
dimanche 11 novembre à partir de 13
heures le vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reçoit le
cinquième grand prix de vélizy avec au
programme de la vitesse du keirin de
l'élimination du scratch sur la piste on
pourra voir en action le pistard de
l'équipe de france quentin lafargue ou
des futures pépites de la discipline
l'entrée est au tarif de 3 euros et on
referme ce magazine par des photos
insolites le 2
la deuxième édition du trail au wynn
s'est déroulée ce jeudi 1er novembre
dans la commune des clayes-sous-bois et
comme vous pouvez le voir sur ces images
les quartz ce sont pour la plupart à
déguiser pour participer à cette course
100% nature sur le thème d'halloween
au programme un tracé de 19 km un autre
de 10 km au départ du parc jean carillon
le vainqueur pour le 10 km se nomme ou
bad miloud il a bouclé son périple en 36
minutes et 25 secondes pour le 19 km
c'est nicolas du hac qui s'est illustré
en une heure 13 minutes et 23 secondes
une troisième édition devrait être
organisée à l'année prochaine
c'est la fin de cette émission à merci
de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve lundi
prochain pour un nouveau magazine d'ici
là passez une excellente semaine
sportive très belle soirée sur tv et 78
[Musique]